[rock music]
- This is my shop.
My grandfather had built it.
Let me give you a tour.
All right.
So we got
a nice chop saw
for whatever kind of steel
or material
I'm gonna have to cut.
I have a backup anvil
and stand.
Have a nice band saw
just in case,
for whatever I need to cut,
wood-wise,
and then I have
my nice worktable,
where I'll be doing
the majority of my grinding
and final touches.
Uh, I have a nice
sword forge here
that I'll be using.
- My name's Todd Andrews.
I'm a blacksmith
in Eighty Four, Pennsylvania.
Uh, this is my home forge.
Are a--an invention
I saw and copied.
Slide vise.
This enables me
to work on long projects.
Very handy,
uh, very nice to have.
My forge, uh, can be operated
with--by hand,
or with a motor.
Uh, the hood--
I'm highly criticized
about the hood on the forge.
This does--it doesn't
give you enough room
to get things done.
My little gi-giant
power hammer.
Some people
may not recognize it,
because of the safety shield.
They were manufactured
pre-OSHA,
so in the safety realm
of things,
if anything breaks
on the front of the hammer,
chances are, it's just
gonna come at you
and dig into your flesh.
- I have a 280-pound Vulcan
that actually used to be
my grandfather's father's,
so it's over 100 years old.
I have a whole bunch
of tongs,
so whatever I need to do,
I can change 'em, and...
be able to work
with almost any stock.
That's about it
for this shop.
- These are some
of the various items
that I produced, uh,
over the years.
Uh, horseshoe art,
which is, of course,
functional, uh, coat rack.
The animal head elephant,
uh--award-winner.
Uh, to the above--
I call it
the above-average
candle holder.
Metal, uh, or a copper patina
on steel.
Uh, brass inlay.
Uh, course, I make knives.
I don't keep them all.
I try not to fall
in love with them.
This is one of the knives
that started it all.
It's designed
for the left hand.
Uh, it's, uh, my example
of a Rambo knife.
When the movie came out,
I saw the knife in "Rambo,"
and said, "I should--
I should make one of those,"
because that's--you know,
it was--it was influencing,
he was so--so tough,
so hardcore.